an ethical dilemma I think it was an
ethical dilemma but I did have to figure
out how I would handle having
advertising on the blog because I knew
that there would be certain people
saying oh well you know here it goes
it's you know blogs are going to go
downhill because they're gonna have
advertising and they're just going to
shoot him american apparel was one of
the first advertisers on the site and i
was prepared for people to start saying
oh now we're going to start seeing a lot
of american apparel or whatever but that
never happened you know I think the
sincerity and the integrity of the blog
the fact that I was able to have
advertising and it's never affected any
of the work on the site that you never
see anything about american apparel on
the site unless it's something i see and
someone happens to be wearing american
apparel that then absolute integrity and
sincerity is still there I just shot a
big story for burberry big ad campaign
and i announced it because i was very
proud of the work and showed some of the
pictures i really like from that project
and probably did three or four posts but
i didn't put anything in there about you
know where to buy the trenches no
information about it I was just you know
showing the photographs I was very proud
of from that project and the audience
totally understood it you know they they
but at the same time I love burberry and
I was very happy to work with that and I
think the new reality is sometimes
people have a hard time handling the new
reality is you know you know I'm an
artist and I'm a I guess you know that's
the only way you could say I'm really
considered myself a journalist I'm not
trying to sell you something I'm not
trying to tell you the story of these
things I'm just showing you my pictures
so I feel totally comfortable saying i
love burberry or Ralph Lauren or
whatever because those are things that I
like and so that's uh you know that's
hard for some people to be able to
understand that but because it's so
consistent and I've been so consistent
in how I present those things and how I
let them be manifest themselves on the
blog that's what I think has been able
to keep the sincerity and keep the
audience believing in what I do
you